we're talking today about integrating
with respect to time and I want you to
call your mind back to when we first a
couple of lessons ago introduced this
topic and we said hey if you have not
just an XY graph but a displacement time
graph so your vertical axis is now X and
it's your position relative to some
fixed point and then your horizontal
axis is your T your time axis right if
you've got a displacement graph then
we've established that the first
derivative with respect to time X dot
right it gives you the velocity graph
right you've already done this a couple
of times where you put them on the same
same thing right and I just want you to
focus on what that means geometrically
right the gradient of this tangent the
gradient this tangent corresponds to how
fast are you going and in what direction
yeah that's that that's the vector part
of velocity so for instance see this
component here this particular tangent
I've drawn it's a going in the
decreasing direction which is wide down
here the velocity graph is negative does
that make sense yeah and look what
happens as the velocity graph approaches
zero what's the displacement graph doing
the displacement graph is well then it's
slowing down because velocity is going
towards zero does that make sense so
there is a there's a stationary point
there because velocity is zero yes now
quickly right before I move past this
just as an aside you can see this is my
like my taient axis okay and so just
because I was a bit lazy I just put a
parabola on there and I didn't make
anything special about it in terms of
its domain restrictions so over here
like if this is the axis right down the
middle the displacement axis what values
of time am I having over here on the
left hand side what values these are
negative values of time now this is not
a rhetorical question about what you
think about it can we have negative
values of time
and the answer is can I have negative
value time the answer is it depends
right now if you have a question and it
says an object starts moving at time
zero then that means for all intents and
purposes there is no such thing as
negative time but I could just as
equally say time zero is midnight okay
and then and then you know it starts
going through in hours well there is
such a thing as negative time it's just
it's last night right that's that's all
that means
okay and in fact just like with
displacement we can define displacement
to have zero at different spots like at
the surface of the water from that ball
that lady throwing that um thing off the
breach right
or maybe the zero is where the girl is
the lady starts with her weight so you
can you can change where your
displacement zero is you can change
where your time zero is as well okay now
if we understand them that
differentiating from displacement gives
us with a lot velocity well therefore it
stands to reason that if you integrate
instead of differentiate right you
should go in wall in the opposite
direction right now if I gave you the
velocity graph or the velocity function
rather you should then be able to
integrate and get the displacement graph
right but just stop for a minute don't
have any pens in your house this room
should think why did we introduce the
idea of integration think back to like
when we first met this topic what
problem was at solving it was solving
the problem of area right which means
that onto your diagram I'd love you to
add this which means that if you have an
area underneath the velocity graph this
is really important go say it twice cuz
such a weird idea right an area
underneath the velocity graph is the
same as a change in displacement on the
displacement graph right so for example
have a look at this one right here's my
velocity rap between time one time -
okay I've chosen a very simple example
so my velocity graph is just a straight
line okay so if you have a look at the
area underneath the graph what's this
purple shape what is the shape it's a
trapezium
which means that its area is 1/2 times
the what am I thinking on H on - that's
the height the height of the trapezium
times the average I've already done 1/2
times the sum of the two
parallel sides yeah now you can actually
have a look this is why I needed I
couldn't draw it freehand right you can
actually have a look this side here
which is parallel is is two in length
this side here is four in length so
that's why my area calculation over here
is 1/2 times H which is one times a plus
B which is 2 plus 4 yeah so when you go
ahead and cross that you get 3 the area
underneath the curve the velocity curve
from 1 to 2 that area is 3 what that
corresponds to is between time 1 and
time 2 the displacement has changed from
3 to 6 3 units does that make sense
right so what we're doing here is going
in the opposite direction working out a
displacement and it corresponds to area
ok now I want to push on this intuition
a little more let me put this aside for
a minute so I have a man he's jogging at
this particular speed 10 kilometers per
hour and I'm gonna start him off 20
kilometers from his home ok
so what I'd like us to do now is draw
the displacement yeah he's running for
some like that ok a running away from
whatever or you can we're going to draw
the displacement time graph and the
velocity time graph and then I want us
to think about this ok so let's make him
run in the opposite direction to him
home ok so what that means is if I just
think about my displacement time graph
so displacement time ok if he begins to
20 kilometers from home then that means
my intercept here on the displacement
axis is going to be 20 that's where he
begins not at the origin and because he
has a constant velocity ok that means
that this displacement graph he's just
gonna get further and further and
further away ok so for instance if I
have a look at say when is he going to
be if that's 10 that's 20 that's 30 at
what time will he be 30 kilometers away
from home after after 1 hour all right
so that means over here so that means
time 1 and then we have a look at say
when he's 40 that should be at time
- okay so this is our displacement time
graph on the same axis if you've got
another color there we can also put in
our velocity time graph right so I'm
gonna just complete this out I might put
this X actually over here so now when I
put you in my velocity graph well what's
it gonna look like can you tell me what
it'll look like
this is his velocity does it ever change
not in the context of this question I
haven't said anything so it's just going
to be a horizontal line horizontal line
like this this is X dot and it's at 10
okay now when we have a look at a simple
example like this I you know we drew
this graph before between time 1 and
time 2 ok if I have a look if I
integrate oops
X dot right this is the velocity from
time one to time two with respect to
time it's the time axis right before we
go ahead and calculate what it is what
will the shape in what does it look like
think carefully this is the integral of
this this is an area question right what
area does it correspond to what shape is
it this is just going to be a rectangle
right are you okay with that like this
is the X dot graph and then between 1 &
2 there's the shape okay so I could go
ahead and I could do like calculus and
that kind of thing but being that this
is just an area of a rectangle can you
tell me I should stay with orange can
you tell me how I work it out what's the
area of a rectangle its length times
breadth right which in this case will be
1 times 10 because that's how tall it is
right sorry my horizontal and vertical
axes are so different
okay so that of course is 10 now get
this with me right write this underneath
because this is so important right you
just told me that area equals length
times breath
but what you've just worked out is not
just an area but that area represents
what what is that Tim what does that
correspond to
it's it's the it happens to the gradient
cuz I've gone from one unit but because
I've integrated the velocity graph it's
given me a change in displacement look
here I am at time one and I go up to
time to a distance of ten kilometers
right so instead of saying just area I
can say well that's displacement right
that's actually what I've calculated
right it's like a distance yeah well
that distance has a horizontal and a
vertical component it's actually the
same as saying speed times time do you
recognize this this is the distance
speed time the triangle that we've been
used to for so long okay except it
literally corresponds to those things
because this orange height here what
does it represent it's it's the speed
the velocity right
what about horizontally what does that
represent it represents time do you see
what's happening now I've just chosen
this example because a simple rectangle
okay but when we integrate weird
wonderful shapes all we're saying is you
divide up your weird wonderful curved
thing into an infinite series of
rectangles that's all they are right so
when you integrate velocity with respect
to time you're just saying you know
width of the sorry width of the
rectangle height of the rectangle you're
just doing distance distance distance
and just adding them all up right that's
why you get displacement okay so there
are some really nice visual
interpretations already at a particular
picture there we go like say this one
now this is the same graph you drew
before you don't need to draw it onto
yours cause it's going to become too
busy but I just want you to think with
me as to what this means
think about what it means
yeah good question okay so you can see
what this purple thing is right I'm
integrating this particular thing from
some negative value over to some
positive value right now it looks pretty
symmetrical right when you calculate
this integral not the area the integral
what do you think will your answer be it
should be zero right because you've got
a negative and eres this is signed area
right this is a negative this is a
positive it's zero but integrating the
velocity graph gives you displacements
so what does that mean you haven't moved
anywhere or you've moved nowhere
relative to yourself that's what the
blue arrow is you see he started here
he's ended on this interval he's ended
on the same spot displacement zero does
that make sense so you need to think
visually about what's going on please
please please do not just think about
this as I'm just doing more calculus and
I'm just going through the motions right
you must interpret that's what
distinguishes this from all the
integration you've done in the past does
that make sense